another John Wick movie yeah we're
thinking he's back but where's he back
from he is a full timeline of John
Wick's life as far as we know it so far
morning spoilers ahead for John Wick
chapter 4.
not much is known about John Wick's
early life but we do learn in the series
third movie that John Wick is not his
real name when he's desperate for
assistance after being declared
excommunicado he goes to see the
director and during their meeting John's
real name and Heritage is revealed to
the audience
[Music]
John States us as the last of his
particular tribe is enough to ensure him
safe passage from New York City to
Casablanca beyond that the only thing we
can reliably say about John Wick's early
life is that at some point he may have
entered the United States Marine Corps
which we can guess because of the tattoo
across his upper back it reads forteous
Futuna or duvat which is Latin for
fortune favors the Bold the motto of the
third Marine regiment stationed in
Kaneohe Bay Hawaii which itself is
likely a nod to read his own Hawaiian
heritage
the John Wick films don't tell us
exactly when or how Jon became a killer
for hire but they do suggest certain
things namely the Wix Chief Mentor may
have been Marcus his friend and fellow
assassin who takes a contract to kill
him in the first film it's quite
possible they served in the military
together and the Marcus took up the
Hitman life first Paving the way for a
slightly younger friend to eventually
join up however their bond developed
Marcus seems to have taught Jon quite a
few of his tricks what we do know for
sure is that John was a natural Hitman
and quickly developed a reputation that
earned in the nickname Baba Yaga he was
a boogeyman for the most dangerous
people in the world and he could kill
with tremendous efficiency in just about
any way he had to I once saw him killed
three men and
with a bouncer at some points during his
career was a sought after and feared
assassin John did some kind of favor for
his friend Sophia which called for her
to offer him a Blood Oath marker which
he could later cash in at some point in
his career as an assassin Wick came
under the employee of Vigo torresoff a
mob boss with big Ambitions then though
the life he'd chosen was supposed to be
permanent Wick approached tarasoft and
asked to leave because he was in love
with a woman so I made a deal with him
I gave him an impossible task tarasoft
does not go into specifics in the films
but Wick's legendary impossible task was
apparently a series of assassinations
and the bodies he buried that day paved
the way for taurusoff and his family to
rise up to the ranks of organized crime
having accomplished his impossible task
Wick was allowed to retire from his life
as a contract Killer and Tara soft
became one of the most powerful men in
the crime World drawing the impossible
task though Rick also saw the help of
his friends Santino d'antonio who
secured a Blood Oath marker from wick
for his trouble what the hell were you
thinking giving a market woman like
Santino d'antonio
only way I could get out
after the impossible task was completed
Wick left the world of crime going so
far as to bury his guns and remain in
Gold under concrete in his basement he
married Helen and the two settled into a
happy life together that's happiness
unfortunately was not to last at some
point in the course of their marriage
Helen fell ill the illness was terminal
and she died shortly before the events
of the first John Wick film the films
rarely elaborate on Helen or her Illness
but we know that her death greatly
impacted Jon to the point that he's
willing to stay alive if only to
remember her to ease his pain at some
point before her death she arranged for
a puppy to be delivered to his doorstep
to help him move on
the main events of the first John Wick
film begin just days after Helen's death
when several years of apparently passed
since John's retirement as an assassin
we can infer this because Vigo Torres
soft's son Joseph seems to be the only
person in the criminal underworld who
doesn't know who John is Yosef and his
friends decide after seeing Wick's
Classic Ford Mustang to Stage a home
invasion and steal the car they also
kill Wick's new puppy Daisy in the
process and make the mistake of leaving
Wick alive it's not what you did son
with angers me soon
it's who you did it to when Joseph takes
a Mustang to a Job Shop to have its Vin
changed word begins to spread in the
Underworld of the sin he's just
committed while John digs up his guns
and gold and prepares to go on a quest
for vengeance Vigo Tara soft berates his
son for what he's done but still
prepares to go to war with Wick even
taking out a contract to have Wick
killed in the process some of the most
talented assassins in the world try and
fail to stop work as he burns through
the tarasoft family eventually killing
Yosef and Vigo eventually the Vendetta
ends at The Chop Shop of viggo's brother
Abram where Wick retrieves his Karen
makes peace he returns home and buries
his guns once more
John returns home with a new unnamed dog
and tries to move on with his life but
his piece is quickly interrupted by
Santino who arrives to cash in on the
marker John had given him years before
in exchange for Santino's assistance
with the impossible task Jon initially
rejects Santino's demands that he under
the marker and Centennial retaliates by
destroying John's home John's journey to
New York City once again and after
encouragement from Winston the owner of
New York's Continental he agrees to meet
with Santino Santino wants to hire John
to assassinate his sister Gianna who is
about to ascend to a seat at the high
table a council of crime Lords that rule
over the whole underworld with his
sister out of the way Santino could
claim the high table seat for himself
but he can't kill her because that would
spark a war among assassins that's why I
need you
John reluctantly agrees and travels to
Italy to kill Gianna when he arrives and
meets Gianna in secret during a
coronation festivities we learned that
the two are old friends though we don't
learn much about their history knowing
that Jon is bound by a Blood Oath to
carry out the hit Gianna slits her rest
in an effort to die in her own terms as
she loses Consciousness in a bath John
puts a bullet in her head
even as he was honoring the marker by
killing Gianna John was under
surveillance from Santino's Chief
bodyguard aerys in the catacombs beneath
Gianna's compound Santino's henchman
attack John Santino always intended into
double cross's old friend entire pool
possible Loose Ends connected to his
coup against his sister Jon fights his
way out and returns to New York City
where he learns that Santino has taken
out a 7 million dollar contract against
him as a public show of Vengeance for
his sister's death Gianna's loyal
bodyguard Cassian attempts to cash in on
this contract and Avenger but Jon
defeats him in combat and ultimately
seeks Refuge with the Bowery King
somebody please get this man a gun he
gives him a gun with seven bullets which
he can use to seek Vengeance against
Santino Jon fights his way through
Santino's guards but Santino himself
seeks refuge in the Continental where
one of the chief rules is that no blood
can be spilled on company grounds Jon
breaks his cardinal rule and shoots
Santino in the head in the hotel's
Lounge forcing Winston to declare him
excommunicado in honor of their
friendship Winston Grant John one hour
to flee before a contract on his life
takes effect Jones response is simple
tell them all
whoever comes
whoever it is
I'll kill them
even before his hour-long grace period
is up other assassins are determined to
kill John Wick seeking Refuge John
retrieves a crucifix and one less marker
from a dummy book in the New York Public
Library and visits the director
you are bound
I am old she says his ticket and Brands
him with the crucifix signifying that
all of his favors have been used up this
is enough to get into Casablanca where
he finds Sofia and he uses the marker
she gave him to ask for a favor that
favor after first battling the Assassin
Barada over one of Sophia's dogs is
ultimately a journey to find the Elder
the only person left who can restore his
status with the high table and allow him
to continue living his life John
explains that he wants to keep living so
that he can carry on the memory of his
wife Helen and the Elder offers him a
deal if John will show his loyalty by
killing Winston and continuing to serve
the high table as an assassin he can go
on living John agrees to this deal
severing his own ring finger and giving
his wedding ring to the Elder as a sign
of devotion
while John is overseas attempting to
restore his status with a high table and
adjudicator arrives in New York to
dispatch Justice on behalf of the high
table for the wrongs done in John Wick
chapter 2. to carry this out the
adjudicator recruits zero a loyal
assassin and they begin their work for
his role in giving John a one-hour Head
Start the adjudicator Tells Winston that
he has seven days to get his Affairs in
order at such time your successor will
be named
There Are Rules they are the only things
that separate us the adjudicator then
goes to the director and the retribution
for her role in letting John Escape has
zero plunge a sword through both of her
hands they then visit the Bowery King as
punishment for providing the gun in
seven bullets Jon used to kill Santino
and Continental grounds the adjudicator
orders zero to give the Barry King seven
Cuts with his sword the Bowery King is
severely wounded but survives
John returns to New York City after his
meeting with the Elder but his
restoration to service with the high
table would not be complete until he
kills Winston with Zero's men in Pursuit
both John and Winston decide to deny
their orders from the table Winston
refuses to step down as manager of the
continental and John refuses to kill his
old friend in Wisconsin adjudicator
declares the New York City Continental
to beat it consecrated and a squad of
high table and forces arrived to kill
Winston John and everyone loyal to them
including the continental's concierge
Sharon though they initially struggled
to fight off the SWAT like enforcers
with their bulletproof armor Jon and
Sharon defeat the squad with
armor-piercing rounds Jon then goes on
to battle zero and his men narrowly
walking away Victorious Winston
meanwhile uses his defeat of the high
table in forces as leverage to Parlay
with the adjudicator who decides to
frame the defense of the Continental as
a show of strength from Winston to prove
his loyalty to the high table Winston
shoots John who falls off the hotel roof
the adjudicator agrees to reconsecrate
the continental and restore Winston to
power but when they look for Jon's body
in the alley he's gone the adjudicator
makes it clear that Jon remains a threat
to both Winston and to the high table
which Winston is also aware of himself
Jon severely wounded but alive is
transported to the Barry King by his
servants the King still suffering from
his sword wounds and struggling to walk
makes it clear that he does not accept
the punishment of the high table the
Barry King declares that he's ready to
wage war against the table for their
attempt to remove him from his territory
and ask John if he's also ready to fight
back he yeah
yeah we don't know exactly how much time
passes between chapter 3 and chapter 4
of the John Wick Saga Burt's chapter 4
picks up enough time has passed on both
Jon and the Bowery King have recovered
from their wounds and Jon declares
himself ready to take the fight to the
high table once again John's out for
Revenge after the table betrayed him at
the end of chapter 3 and the Elder tells
him that no matter what he does at this
point he's Marked for Death killing the
Elder will not make a difference but Jon
does it anyway
following John's murder of the Elder
High table member Marky Vincent de
gramand gathers the signatures of the
other table members and applies his vast
resources to taking out Wix allies one
by one he starts by murdering Sharon and
detonating a bomb inside the Continental
the Marquis also tasks a bounty hunter
calling himself nobody and John's old
friend and retired assassin Kane with
locating and killing John Wick meanwhile
John Hyde's house at the Osaka
Continental in Japan under the care of
another old Ally Koji shimazu and his
daughter Akira the Marquis Chief
Lieutenant arrives with his men and
informs Koji that the Ahsoka Hotel will
be de-consecrated but Koji is not about
to go down without a fight
Koji and his men Engage The High tables
forces in battle and as Jon Battles
Through the Assassins he learns that
Kane has arrived with orders to put him
down Les Kane's own daughter be harmed
by the table in order to buy John some
time Koji engages Kane in adore more
John himself heads out the back of the
building fighting through more high
table Killers along the way meanwhile at
the Continental it came reluctantly
kills Koji and tells Akira that he will
be waiting should she ever want revenge
soon after that fight Kane is able to
track Jon's whereabouts and the bowels
of the Osaka Continental they begin a
duel only to be interrupted by nobody
who tries to shoot Jon and creates an
opening for him to flee on a train John
reunites with Akira who promises him
that if he doesn't kill Kane she will
they part ways and John heads to New
York
John reunites with Winston at Sharon's
gravesite and learns that his old friend
is hungry for revenge against the
Marquee while Jon views the situation as
an endless fight Winston has a better
idea challenge a marquee to a single
combat doll in the tradition of the high
table's old laws there's just one
problem John is no longer a member of a
table sanctioned family having torn his
ticket with the Rusk Aroma in chapter
three I don't sit at the table your
family does hoping to earn his way back
into the rescue Roma fold Jon travels to
Berlin where current family leader Katya
orders him to kill a man named Killer
who murdered the previous head of the
Rusk Aroma though it's a struggle Jon
fights his way through Killer's club and
finally escapes back to the rescue Roma
with proof of Killer's death Katia keeps
a promise and Brands him with the Rusk
of Roma Crest the thus allowing him to
issue a challenge to the Marquee the
Marquee reluctantly accepts the
challenge but there is one twist rather
than fight Jon himself the Marquee names
Kane his stand-in for the fight
once both are Marquis and John are in
Paris the door is set to take place the
following day at sunrise at the secret
under the watchful lie of the harbinger
in an effort to subvert this samaki
increases a bounty on Jon's head
ensuring that every killer in Paris will
spend the entire night before the duel
trying to Snuff him out if Jon doesn't
make it to the church by Sunrise he will
forfeit the door and be executed luckily
for Jon the Barry King arrives in Paris
just in time to give him a new weapon
and the new Kevlar infused suit Jon then
fights his way towards the church with
dozens of Assassins on his Trail while
fighting his way through a house Jon
saves nobody's dog thus winning nobody
over to his side but even that's not the
end of the battle John has to ascend
more than 200 steps to get to the church
and falls all the way down them until
Kane and nobody intervene setting the
stage for The Showdown with the Marquee
the terms of the door are simple John
and Kane are each given a single shot
pistol told to walk out 30 paces and
then fire if they're both still capable
of continuing they'll move forward 10
more spaces and fire again and again
until one of them goes down eventually
John and Kane move in for the 10 Pace
Face-Off both bleeding heavily on the
third shot Kane strikes John in the
Torso knocking him down the Marquee
steps in and takes the pistol but Jon
reveals that he never fired his weapon a
third time and shoots the Marquee in the
head winning the door John is freed from
all high table obligations that's arcade
and his daughter while Winston has
reinstated as head of the New York
Continental
buys the cane that makes his way down to
the steps of the church still bleeding
profusely there with images of his wife
in his head he says her name and
seemingly dies
Winston and the Bowery King returned to
New York or they resume their roles
within the city's criminal Network they
visit John's grave right next to his
wives and pay their respects but Winston
implies the connection to the rescue
Roma and calls John my son before
leaving though it's clear that John is
meant to appear dead chapter 4 leaves
certain aspects of his passing
somewhat's ambiguous whatever the case
John Wick is well and truly gone at
least for now you're going to die
maybe not in a post-credits scene
however the film reveals that some
conflicts remain ongoing while Kane
walks around a city listening to his
daughter played a violin for a crowd of
onlookers on the street Akira approaches
with a box cutter in hand the sermon to
make good on her promise to kill Kane if
John did not both of their Fates are
left ambiguous while we don't yet know
for sure if we'll see a continuation of
the John Wick story we do know that the
franchise lives on in the form of two
more upcoming projects a prequel series
titled the Continental set up the hotel
of the same name is headed to Peacock
soon while the spin-off movie titled
ballerina co-starring Keanu Reeves as
John Wick is slated to hit theaters in
the coming years
thank you